man: Welcome to Google I/O.
[upbeat music]
[man singing indistinctly]
♫IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0♫
♫offline functionality improved access-ability de-crease your la-ten-cy♫
♫more fast applications with persistent storage and cacheable resources♫
♫rich in-browser video and audio (no plugin yo) geolocation api enables apps for on the go♫
♫write your multimedia, location service with regular javascript♫
♫IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0♫
♫query up and down your client-side, executing SQL states.♫
♫put my files inside your manifest to startup fast♫
♫see and play all of your buttons; attribute "controls"♫
♫IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0♫
♫vector graphics client-side, with drag & drop from low to high mean high-fi-del-ity UIs♫
♫immersive experience. dynamic images, drawings and drag events♫
♫independent background scripts performing computation tricks, communication APIs for multi-origin post events♫
♫maintain page responsiveness, execute workers, safe cross-domain messages♫
♫IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0♫
♫pose your polygons because i'm gonna paint in JS♫
♫take it off, put it down, move around, never stop♫
♫i'm running tasks behind your back, but you will never be disturbed♫
♫IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0♫
♫vector graphics client-side, with drag & drop from low to high mean high-fi-del-ity UIs♫
♫immersive experience. dynamic images, drawings and drag events♫
♫independent background scripts performing computation tricks, communication APIs for multi-origin post events♫
♫maintain page responsiveness, execute workers, safe cross-domain messages♫
♫IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0♫
♫pose your polygons because i'm gonna paint in JS♫
♫take it off, put it down, move around, never stop♫
♫i'm running tasks behind your back, but you will never be disturbed♫
♫IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0 ... IO 5.0♫